le ministre l'intérieur qui a été prise
en flagrant délit d'excès de vitesse sur
les routes si l'on en croit le magazine
auto plus un autre membre du
gouvernement le ministre des transports
gilles de robien a aussi été épinglée
tous deux se rendait à la présentation
du premier radar automatisé
claudine gilbert nathalie berthier un
excès de vitesse de 33 kilomètres par
heure dans la 607 peugeot
il n'est par les journalistes de
l'hebdomadaire auto plus le ministre de
l'intérieur nicolas sarkozy fils à
l'inauguration des nouveaux radars
le chauffeur risquerait alors trois
points de son permis et une amende de
plus de 100 euros peu après un second
contrevenants de haut vol dans la
renault selon auto plus
ce serait gilles de robien ministre des
transports le voici trois kilomètres
plus loin
vantant justement les mérites et berrada
routier le but de ces radars c'est des
premiers justement dans les endroits qui
sont connus comme étant les plus
accidentogènes
dans son numéro du 11 novembre autoplus
s'étonne du décalage entre les paroles
des ministres et leurs agissements sur
la route
le jour où vous allez inaugurer une
série de nouvelles cabines radars
automatisés et que vous avez un discours
qui dit aujourd'hui maintenant c'est
tolérance zéro
la moindre des choses c'est qu'au moins
ce jour-là vous essayer de montrer
l'exemple
même si c'est très difficile de
respecter ces limitations de vitesse sur
des deux fois deux voies qui sont très
belles très là au moins vous montrez
l'exemple terre que même ce jour là ils
ne sont même pas capables de le faire
nicolas sarkozy n'a pas répondu à ces
accusations ses services 10 vérifiée
pour l'instant les affirmations de
l'hebdomadaire
quant à gilles de robien il ne conteste
pas les excès de vitesse il déclare que
pour lui comme pour beaucoup de gens il
y a encore des progrès à faire pour
changer les mauvaises habitudes